hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
the senate judiciary committee will act
this week to subpoena the ceos of
twitter and facebook
to testify about their site's
restrictions on a controversial new york
post article
republicans say is damaging to democrats
host of media buzz howard kurtz
weighs in on the criticism surrounding
social media sites limiting the reach of
the report
and the final days of a highly
contentious presidential race
as americans focus on november 3rd
there's been plenty of speculation and
questions about polling who is winning
where and which polls to trust
darren shaw a member of the fox news
decision desk and co-director of the fox
news poll
discusses the science of polling and
what pollsters are doing differently
this election season plus commentary
from fox news contributor kat timf
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast player
by going to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm maria bartiromo i'm greg gutfeld i'm
tammy bruce
and this is the fox news rundown
wednesday october 21st 2020
i'm dave anthony how facebook and
twitter covered
or republicans say covered up a
controversial hunter biden
report has social media under more
scrutiny
these actions by these two uh silicon
valley
companies actually end up drawing far
more attention
to the new york post under biden story
that would have been the case otherwise
so it
accomplished the exact opposite of what
they intended
i'm jessica rosenthal the polls are
tightening and while most
pollsters still say the numbers give an
edge to joe biden
right now a couple weeks out there are
definitely pathways for trump to win and
people who don't
say that are setting themselves up to
look like fools again four years from
now
and i'm kat timp i've got the final word
on the fox news rundown
it's made republicans even more
anti-social media
the way people were blocked from sharing
a controversial story online about joe
biden's son
hunter senator ted cruz wants to
question the ceos of facebook and
twitter
at a hearing and we need answers before
the election because this is
dangerous it is a real threat to free
speech
the new york post broke the story that a
laptop purportedly belonging to hunter
biden was said to be abandoned at a
delaware computer repair shop
emails were found between biden and a
ukrainian business leader
wanting his help dealing with an
investigation and then thanking biden
for setting up a meeting with his then
vice president father though
the biden campaign says there's no
official record of any such meeting
but president trump told fox and friends
he wants attorney general bill
barr to investigate and he's got to act
fast he's got to appoint somebody
this is major corruption and this has to
be known about before the election the
new york post's op-ed editor so rob
amari
also told fox on tuesday this is solidly
deeply reported material and more
corroborated than any
number of anti-trump stories that
appeared over the past four years
but others in the media are skeptical
there are even some at the post
questioning the credibility of the biden
story including one of its
writers who reportedly didn't want his
name on it
many democrats also dismissed the
reporting because the repair shop owner
is a republican
who supposedly gave the emails and other
info to
trump lawyer rudy giuliani house
intelligence committee chairman adam
schiff told cnn
it looks like russian meddling to him
clearly the origins of this whole
uh smear are from the kremlin
now the director of national
intelligence john ratcliffe told fox
with regard to hunter biden's laptop
being part of a russian disinformation
campaign in the intelligence community
believing that or assessing that
is simply not true back to social media
democratic senator chris coons
says those companies were following
sound policies
to not spread things that are utterly
unreliable
that have been debunked and where their
origin is
untrustworthy what does our media critic
think
uh what was a bit shocking uh an even
bigger surprise than the
quote october surprise itself is the way
that twitter
and facebook engage with outright
censorship to try to suppress this story
howie kurtz hosts media buzz on the fox
news channel and has a media buzz
meter podcast there are a lot of
questions that can be raised about the
new york post handling of this have the
emails
from hunter biden been confirmed how is
it that rudy giuliani got involved
did the laptops really go into a blind
computer owner
shop in delaware i mean you can't make
this stuff up
but nevertheless you know this was a
story published by one of america's
largest newspapers and twitter in
particular
just completely engaged in censorship
couldn't share it couldn't send it to
anybody else in direct message then
realized
what a colossal blunder this was backed
off in about two days and finally
lifted the ban this after locking the
trump campaign's account so
i think this gave absolute ammunition to
president trump conservatives and
anybody who's been critical of the
social media giants
uh for putting their collective thumb on
the digital scale
now the idea behind the ban or not
letting people
share it was that that this could have
been hacked material correct
uh that was the rationale that twitter
gave facebook took a different
route and uh limited the distribution
while having an outside fact checker
look into it
i don't know it's been several days
whatever happened to this outside
fact checker uh idea i think it was a
kind of a fig leaf
in the case of twitter yeah it said hack
material is really bad
and then two days later he said well
hack material is okay you can share it
as long as you're not the hacker
the point is it backfired not just in
terms of the fact that there's going to
be a capitol hill hearing and the ceos
of these companies are going to get
beaten up but
it these actions by these two
silicon valley companies actually end up
drawing
far more attention to the new york post
under biden story than would have been
the case
otherwise so it accomplished the exact
opposite
of what they intended do you think it's
a tough job though
for social media because people use it
for all sorts of reasons including for
the spreading of misinformation if they
want i mean it's a platform that allows
them to do that if they can
so it's not easy for for twitter and for
facebook is it
you know what it's time for them to grow
up they face the same challenges that
every news organization faces what
happens when you get an ad with unproven
claims
what happens when you have a source who
has
sensational allegations that perhaps
there is only fragmentary evidence of
what do you do about sources that have
agendas
every local television station national
network newspaper magazine deals with
this
facebook and twitter have made a huge
amount of money and used to be
incredibly popular i mean they're still
popular in terms of users but in terms
of their reputation
by pretending you know we're just like
the electric company like people post
whatever they want we don't
have anything to say about it it's not
our fault we have legal immunity
well they're slowly been coming to grips
with well we won't allow hate speech
well we won't allow bullying well we
won't around allow disinformation and
now in the
final weeks of a heated campaign they're
realizing how hard it is to make these
decisions i agree with the premise of
your question but they should have dealt
with this
long ago rather than pretend that
they're not media companies they are in
fact
uh the most influential media companies
in history let's go to the fact-checking
part i mean that's a big thing
in the last several years fact checkers
everybody's got a fact checker goes
through all the information but
how easy is it to actually fact check
stories that
they come out at being researched by the
post in this case or something the new
york times did with anonymous sources
how do you fact check those
um sometimes with great difficulty and
major organizations like the new york
times and the washington post and others
have attempted and failed they say
to authenticate that these are actually
hunter biden's emails now
i i think they probably are only because
the biden campaign hasn't specifically
denied the authenticity of these emails
but at the same time
the fact-checking part of it is it's
hard to prove a negative
you unless a source turns or a document
turns out to be a forgery
when somebody makes a claim it can be
difficult to say well that story is
absolutely
untrue and because the media is so
widely distrusted these days and
thanks in no small part to president
trump's constant attacks
many people now do not trust the fact
checkers what if
the information in this hunter biden
story
did come from ukraine or did come from
russia what if it really was hacked
information but
the emails and the material is actually
real
then what well that would be the same
questions that were raised in 2016 when
the fact that wikileaks was involved in
hacking
democratic national committee and emails
and hillary clinton
emails and so forth people said oh
tut-tut that's really unfortunate and
now here's the story and everybody would
go wild over the story
but i would say i would just raise a
larger point and that is
look uh i don't think we need that much
more evidence
that hunter biden who was a drug addict
uh was engaged in very unseemly
profiteering
off of his father's high position
now it still hasn't been proven that joe
biden
did anything wrong now that this meeting
that may or may not have taken place
with a guy from the
ukrainian engineering company burisma if
biden was found to have not told the
truth
about that well that would um certainly
go
to the heart of his credibility and that
would be important but by and large
um i think these emails confirm and
perhaps amplify what we already knew
which is that joe biden had a son and
maybe he looked the other way
who was trying to make a lot of money in
places where he had no qualifications or
expertise
because his dad was vice president the
media itself
hasn't really wanted to cover this story
at least there have been
not nearly as much coverage in other
networks fox has covered a lot more than
msnbc or cnn
and the cnn and the msnbc coverage has
it been just more or less
trying to debunk it well for the first
24 hours after the story broke there was
virtually no coverage on cnn or msnbc
they attempted to ignore their stories i
thought it was a
real failing that in an hour and a half
of air time
during that abc town hall with joe biden
george stephanopoulos didn't bring up
a single question about hunter biden if
only to give the former vice president a
chance
to say what he ever he wanted to say now
i don't think everybody is ignoring him
for example you know we don't get any
chances to question binding doesn't
allow much press access but
when he was coming in or out of an event
cbs reporter asked him a very simple
question he said
do you have any comment on the new york
post story on hunter biden
and the former vp snapped at him said
it's a smear
the story was a smear it's his right to
say and then went after the reporter
saying um uh i'm not surprised that you
would ask that question that's the kind
of question that you would ask
well it's a legitimate question and i do
think you can make a case that
so much of the mainstream media is so
heavily invested
in um hostility toward president trump
and at this point for many of them not
all but many of them i would say his
defeat
that they are going easy on these
questions raised by biden i don't think
that
the election is going to turn on hunter
biden by any means i think the pandemic
the economy
and other host to home issues will
ultimately decide this election
but we should make some attempt to hold
both candidates to a similar standard
howie just mentioned that joe biden town
hall it was on at the same time
last thursday as the nbc news town hall
featuring president trump
who said at a rally in arizona on monday
so i had savannah guthrie the other
night she was
she was like a crazed lunatic she was
literally rising out of her chair and
she's screaming questions he complains
joe biden gets treated differently well
i was pretty critical myself i mean
having to watch both of those
uh simultaneously which is not something
i recommend you try at home it's kind of
difficult
it was tough i tried flipping back and
forth it wasn't easy yeah
look savannah guthrie came out uh like a
boxer with her fists up
first 20 minutes she ignored the town
hall audience and just pummeled the
president
uh on his personal handling of coven 19
on white supremacist on cueing on at one
point she likened him to a crazy uncle
uh i think she was under a lot of
pressure because a lot of people at nbc
and especially
msnbc didn't think that town hall should
have been held at all
stephanopoulos has his own style but i
think he was a little bit tougher when
he did his own
abc town hall with president trump
certainly the president seems to think
so
and he asked joe biden a lot of good
questions but they were policy questions
he didn't follow up much except on the
question
of court backing where biden continued
to be evasive and
he he deferred much more to the audience
they were after all town halls but
he never questioned biden's record
character credibility it was more like
well tell us what you
plan you would have on this that or the
other thing and so the contrast between
those two
events happening simultaneously in place
of the second cancelled debate
was so stark was so night and day that i
think it reinforced
people's view that the president always
gets
aggressive bordering on prosecutorial
questioning and joe biden not so much
was the media more curious
[Applause]
about the steele dossier and all of the
stuff with
donald trump and president trump as his
got you know as he won the election and
got into his first year
a lot of that stuff was never verified
either correct
well i'm not in the camp that says that
because the theo dossier was unverified
and
you know and the people surrounding it
had agendas that therefore everything
that followed is completely illegitimate
i mean that's what the president says
russia investigation was a hoax i mean
keep in mind it was the president's own
deputy attorney general who appointed
robert mueller who conducted this
investigation
a bunch of people got indicted some went
to jail or pleaded guilty
um there were questions raised about
some of the president's conduct
nevertheless
ultimately he was right there was no
collusion with russia that could be
proven on his part or anybody
close to him um but i don't fall into
the camp that says therefore
because there were problems with that
shaky steel dossier which i always was
skeptical of and everybody should have
been skeptical of
um that every single thing that followed
from that was not legitimate journalism
howie kurtz host of media buzz on the
fox news channel also the media buzz
meter podcast thanks very much for
joining us again
thanks very good to talk to
this is kat temp with your fox news
commentary coming up
do you believe some of us see a poll and
think okay that means something
others it seems increasingly say no it
does not
and sometimes the poll matters only if
we wanted to
this was president trump in late july
we're leading in arizona we're leading
nicely in florida i think our poll
numbers are very good
we're leading substantially in georgia i
mean
we get a lot of suppression polls we get
a lot of fake polls just like we have
fake news i mean it's a terrible thing
the president and his supporters have
said this many times the polls are wrong
referring to polls not internal to the
campaign
but earlier this month the president
liked the results of one survey
a gallup poll just came out that found
that 56 percent of americans say they're
better off today
than they were under sleepy joe and
obama
it's the highest of any president at
this point in this term
think of that 56 many think back four
years ago and think the polls were wrong
were they we're gonna get into it but
first
what generally do the presidential
election day polls indicate right now
joe biden and the democrats generally
but joe biden in particular
with uh something on the order of you
know six to eight point lead
in the national polls darren shaw is a
professor at the university of austin
texas
and a member of the fox news decision
team tighter in the battleground states
and uh and and generally
engaged kind of energized electorate um
which i think has been underrated a
little bit throughout this year and is
coming into focus as we look at some of
the early voting numbers now
so that's sort of one bucket because it
seems to be you know
slightly democratic the other bucket
observation from
polling land is the unbelievable anxiety
and trepidation that pollsters have as
they put these numbers out there
the scars of 2016 which you alluded to
are
fresh and i in my
opinion they're healthy um pollsters
ought to be very
uh attentive to the sorts of issues that
are
i think always out there with polls but
came into you know just very sharp
relief in 2016 so
we are absolutely paranoid about
response rates
about the possibility of uh asymmetries
and who wants to answer a poll
who doesn't and who feels social
desirability
you know not reveal a preference and all
that kind of stuff
they are very much on everybody's mind
people love saying though
that four years ago the polls were wrong
right like to this day oh the polls were
so wrong four years ago
um were they how wrong were they if they
were wrong because
i know the other line of thought is well
wait a second um
national polling did show hillary
clinton ahead
and that was in fact the case right i
mean she won the popular vote
and but but then you drill down on like
battleground states and i read
you know some pollsters got some of
those swing states right but wisconsin
was maybe a fail
when you look back on 2016 and you hear
people say
whoa they were so wrong what's your
response
i think you just told the story the the
national polls
were pretty good and then the statewide
polls it's it's a mixed bag
um but but as a pollster i mean the one
thing that i think is a little craziest
for pollsters to sit back after 2016 and
go
oh we did everything right uh you know
we can't help it if the public's too
dumb to understand
no no no no no no bolsters clearly left
voters and journalists and and all
interested observers with the impression
that there was very little chance for
trump to win and right
and so i i think there weren't there
weren't enough polls
in the key states that was one factor
um and then the accuracy those polls was
was a little funky as
like pennsylvania's interesting story
because in pennsylvania there were a
decent number of polls and they had the
race pretty close i think
we over interpreted were misinterpreted
in other words we
we fell in love with the consistency of
the small clinton lead
ignoring that it was a very small
clinton
lead and and things i do think changed
in the last 10 days
in a state like wisconsin there just
wasn't enough high quality polling
um so i'm not i'm not sure how bad it
was um
that's not to let pollsters off the hook
it's just to say i think there's a mixed
bag depending upon what state we're
talking about
this time around what's interesting is
states that
may not have gotten much attention
in previous years are getting a ton of
polling so not only are you seeing
literally dozens and dozen polls in the
upper midwest states
you're seeing a fair amount of high
quality professional polling in georgia
and texas
some of these places well maybe they're
battlegrounds maybe they're not
that makes me feel a little better about
you know having a
wide range of smart people looking at
these races and bringing data to the
table
but i think the main thing suggested
that you suggested is totally right
which is
you know we gotta have the courage of
our own convictions if i tell you well
you know i think biden's a
you know 60 percent likely to win um and
trump's 40
that 40 is a big deal and right now
a couple weeks out there are definitely
pathways for trump to win and people who
don't
say that are setting themselves up to
look like fools again four years from
now
yeah and the president and his
supporters they do consistently downplay
the polls and they do
sometimes get technical right some of
his surrogates have said look
um there is just a massive over sampling
of democratic voters
is that what's your response to that
kind of criticism
in the particular case of party we've
been
really consistent throughout the years
that like i mentioned the gender balance
of the electorate the
age structure of the electorate the race
and regional structures electorate these
things are
pretty fixed and pretty well known the
party
distribution on election day in 2020 is
unknown
we do not know the proportion of
republicans and democrats that are going
to show up to vote
historically the range has been from
roughly even
to about plus eight democratic you know
the democrats in terms of raw
identification
are the majority part of the united
states they really have been since
franklin roosevelt
ebbed and flowed over time republicans
kind of get to even occasionally
um and i think people conflate that look
because republicans tend to defect at
lower rates
republicans can win facing a party
identification disadvantage that was
obviously true in the reagan years i
mean reagan destroyed walter mondale
yeah yeah even though you know the party
identification structure was still
slightly favorable to the democrats
so partying the vote are not the same
thing party is an attitude
it's not a demographic characteristic
and
we won't it at fox at the university of
texas and other places to do polls we
don't wait by party identification
um because it's an attitude um and once
you
structure the sample such that it it's
it's got the correct
demographics then part identification is
is
gonna shift a little bit as you get
those other features right and then it
is what it is um
now i would say this one caveat in the
statewide polls
we're drawing from lists of registered
voters um
we know what the party distribution is
from the sample we drew and we know what
the party distribution is
uh from our respondents and so we can
actually look at well
you know in pennsylvania this the list
says it should be 47
democratic 42 republican and if we come
out and in the
structure in the actual sample we see
that um
you know the actual respondent structure
is skewed one way or the other
that's an important piece of information
and you know we will act on it right
we'll
wait not to party but we'll wait other
characteristics to make sure that uh
you know that we're accounting for
response by its potentials
and asymmetries in party partisans
willingness to respond
there are a couple of pollsters who do
seem to
like defy the others for lack of a
better word for example the
the trafalgar poll right and you look at
the the real clear politics averages for
each swing state you can see even right
now
trafalgar's often the only poll giving
trump the edge over biden in some
states not all not pennsylvania for
example this time around
um this is the same holster that had
trump winning some key swing states four
years ago
namely michigan and florida right that's
right
i think uh it's nice when when those
pollsters get a lot of attention
and and do long or longish interviews
where they they
talk about their methodology they talk
about their approach and philosophy
um because you want to learn um you know
we're constantly um asking ourselves
if we're missing something if uh our
assumptions are correct
um and and i think you know so i
like listening to different people
who've had success or use different
approaches
um the specific claims that that i've
read from trafalgar are pretty
interesting um
you know it seems to me that they're
they're sort of a mixed methodology that
is they're doing kind of traditional
phones but they're also doing
um online and they're doing some uh
some smart phones and they're doing a
mix of probability and non-probability
polling which i'm always a little
hesitant
about because non-probability sampling
is is
got much much higher degree of
uncertainty than probability sampling
but then the general philosophy briefly
non-probability sampling
uh runs the gamut um it's essentially um
rather than randomly sampling from a
known population you are
essentially taking people who are not
randomly selected
so sometimes that means that they
self-select sometimes it means that
um you're intending a you know a random
sample but from a
particular part of the population and
the problem is
that when when polls that do that offer
a margin of error
uh that's actually technically
inappropriate um there is no margin of
error associated with a non-probability
sample margin of error is
absolutely the assumption that you are
adhering to
probability statistics but back to
trafalgar
you were saying also that there's it's
you're you like learning from
from pollsters like this despite the
non-probability aspect
oh yeah and and he had some points about
um
you know the presence of white less
well-educated voters in the last
election cycle
and uh most of trafalgar's stuff is
obviously being done the state
level and so he's uh very observant to
the characteristics from the uh the
voter files
uh you know when when you read that in
some ways it's reassuring because we're
doing
uh you know we're paying attention to
the same sorts of things
the polls that i've been doing are
actually closer to the average
as opposed to the trafalgar stuff and so
yeah it's just kind of a different mix
but everybody's everybody's got the same
hymnal even if we're not on the same
page
okay so darren final thought um
at this stage two weeks out with
millions of us
having already voted and the the people
may be
hanging onto those ballots last minute
or planning to go day of
being sort of the deciders maybe
um what are your predictions based on
what you're seeing now
you know i think biden has a slight edge
but my goodness after 20
2016 um and and i i do think
it's important to recall that um in the
statewide polls
i think you're really in a situation
right now where the president needs to
flip
about five or six states right you know
he needs to lock down ohio
to win florida carolina arizona
pennsylvania and i might be missing one
um and so on the one hand you think like
well
he's you know he's got a lot of ground
to make up in the national polls he
doesn't need to
um he needs to basically kind of shift
things three to five points
in a very small handful of states so is
there a path
there's absolutely a path um and if the
polls are off
by a couple of points then that path is
even more tractable because it's not
three to five points let's say he only
needs to move it one to three
um and and i think that's important to
remember
um so you know slight biden lead but
my goodness i mean two and a half weeks
that's a lot of time remember when we
thought
impeachment was going to be a big issue
um
so that's an eternity in 2020 as we all
know
wow good point darren shaw thank you so
much for your time
my pleasure
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind few stories have
captivated my attention
quite like the controversy over ice cube
deciding to help president trump craft a
plan that would aim to create jobs for
millions of black americans
part of the reason i'm sure is that i
happen to be a lifelong ice cube fan
once upon a time the projects has been
one of my favorite songs since childhood
wow i've really never been anything but
a libertarian have i
but the bigger one is that it seems to
be one of those news stories where
pretty much everyone is missing the
point
the people on the left who are furious
at ice cube is working with trump are
getting it wrong
the people on the right who are elated
that ice cube is working with trump are
getting it wrong
and the people who say that controversy
proves that people get far too angry at
others for refusing to color inside
partisan lines are
also getting it wrong what it proves is
much worse than that
as a culture we are now largely so hyper
partisan that
far too many of us can't even understand
the concept of someone wanting to focus
on policy and solutions over
partisanship
now i'm not going to weigh in on his
policy proposal itself what's more
seeing as i'm a white person i obviously
don't have any barometer for how this
sort of thing could uniquely
impact someone who is black i can't
relate to any of that
but one thing that i can relate to as
someone who has never aligned herself
with
either major political party is this
increasingly weird phenomenon that
it's not just unacceptable but actually
impossible to exist anywhere but firmly
inside of one camp or the other
that you're either with us or you're
with them that any and all discussions
must be viewed through this prism see
what ice cube is doing here is in fact
so clear they don't even
have to have achieved my lifelong dream
of actually knowing him to be able to
see it
he's choosing policy over partisan
politics
this is blatantly obvious not only
because of the fact that recently he
said he's offered his advice on this to
both campaigns but also because that's
what he's been saying
beginning of last month he tweeted that
he was talking to both sides about his
contract with black america initiative
calling it a totally bipartisan issue
that the country wants to solve ice cube
cares about this issue and he's simply
pursuing all avenues in order
to make his vision a reality people
can't comprehend this it's been so
strange yet familiar to see how people
have been accusing ice cube of being
a hypocrite and using past statements
he's made about how much he doesn't like
trump as evidence of their position
it's honestly crazy to me that people
would see him as not being a fan of
president trump
and him being willing to try and do
whatever it takes regardless of those
personal feelings
to make the country a better place as
being mutually exclusive
they're not mutually exclusive to say
that they are as indisputably wrong
and i have zero idea why that seems to
be so difficult to understand
i have long said that we need to get to
a place where we can focus on finding
solutions to problems over finding ways
that the other side is worse
at this point i guess i may have to put
that kind of talk on the back burner
not because i don't want to see that
become reality because it's still my
ultimate goal
because apparently we have to work on
even being able to
recognize that such a thing is possible
even when we see it happen
right in front of our faces i'm cat tim
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
getting schooled is a podcast hosted by
fox nation's abby hornacek each week
abby and her expert guests tackle topics
we take for granted and help explain the
roots and meanings behind them subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
america is listening to fox news love
fox news click the subscribe button to
get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes